Kip how about that stay trashy tour low
ticket alert moving some picky wikis
gang listen here's the turkey we've been
all over the country we're coming again
it's a good time stand up comedy play
little ayg with the crowd come and hang
yeah guys this is just the first leg in
March we're starting Baltimore Maryland
Virginia Beach Virginia Richmond
Virginia Oklahoma City Dallas Texas
Houston Texas Austin Texas then in April
we're doing New Haven Connecticut
Burlington Vermont then in May we're
doing Tampa Dania Beach Florida Raleigh
North Carolina then in June we're doing
Cleveland and Columbus we're adding more
cities as tickets are going quick some
are about to sell out if they're not
already sold out so don't snooze on us
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage that little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that if they're going to be
classy after just a big old piece of
trash I'm your host Dave Foley coming at
you on a beautiful day we're down here
at antuti's basement a little bit of a
solemn day oh no she's been bedridden
for most of the week okay went to the
doctors it's not looking good uh-oh
right Carlos is coming at you from right
next to me
he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is
international businessman he's my best
fellow you off your meds what the hell's
happening here did you just kill off
duty is that what you're doing you gotta
run that by me dude I give you carte
blanche on the duties but if if you're
gonna throw her down an elevator shift I
gotta know
I gotta make sure her Affairs are in
order coming up for KJ Kevin James Ryan
everybody say a prayer ladies no she's
fine light a candle
uh what's up everybody thanks for tuning
in as always please make sure you're
right if you subscribe on iTunes full
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers are out
and obviously the greatest gosh darn
website of all
time sing it sister I'm talking
www.patreon.com are you garbage baby you
sign up over there you get a bajillion
hours of content I hear it's closing in
on two bajillion hours a concert uh
episodes uh ayg you get
episodes of hard feelings it's a
completely different podcast we got a
whole bunch of videos of Disney videos
dropping this week hopefully if Toby
ever gets his finger out of his head
they're waiting for it clock's ticking
[__]
so you got to say it on the air that way
that way the listeners keep them keep
them on it you know what I mean I'm not
saying it as a boss the fans wanted the
customers are demanded hold them
accountable yes
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the four
mentioned producer
he works the ones and twos he crosses
the t's he dots the eyes we love him
give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody what's up dude what's
up T-Bone know what you're doing this
weekend huh just recovering from that
bus throughout oh yeah you're gonna have
a lawsuit on your hands though that's
good buddy we got a killer guest in the
room today yeah we do I have a standing
bed anyone who wants to jump in on this
can get it whose kid is gonna triple
backflip first Tim butterley Jeremiah
Watkins or Mike Cannon yeah my money's
on Tim butterley
shout out to butts we love you buddy but
that's either here nor there because we
couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly special guests back with us
again today one of our best Pals in
comedies family at this point sure is
one of the funniest guys out there
working he's got multiple stand-up
specials over there
and here's the turkey everybody gets
serious for a second it's going to be
performing at the grammar season he's
dead
it just came in
just got a call from the hospital
she ain't gonna make it each prayer card
is attached to him it's on the back of a
matchbook or something I'm just trying
to set up zombie Tutti that's how you do
this comes back that's The Last of Us
Tony
gang
let's quit screwing around
yeah at The Gramercy theater oh yeah
February 25th if you haven't seen them
if you know him if you love them which
I'm sure you do do yourself a favor and
go check them out he's one of the best
working we love him give it up for my
Canon everybody
[Applause]
shut up she's the one selling the
tickets I wish her well thank you man we
appreciate your thoughts and prayers
yeah well I love the flowers no I love
the fact that that's just a major
storyline shift yeah that's like that's
like Universe altering in in this world
I just said she wasn't feeling well
that's all I don't know what happens it
feels like it's not looking good yeah
and then once you make some miraculous
recovery yeah everybody loves another
dog everybody loves a comeback baby you
know what I'm saying all right I'm with
this okay yeah she's just sad from the
Super Bowl yeah
that's what it is sad she's very sad it
sounds like drug seeking Behavior I
thought it was a soft calling crunch
what's the matter I had a bird's in the
cover
hahaha
how the hell are you buddy I'm good man
thank you excited for the show yeah I'm
fired up dude
I've passed the panic I think I don't
know if you guys experienced that no it
really you really I really panicked till
uh it was over yeah everything I do I
have this phase which typically lasts
right up until the moment where I'm like
who do I think I am whoa every 100
single time and just like and it
typically always goes okay and if it
doesn't it's a funny story to tell but
that is my initial like why why would
you think this is a 100 yeah yeah can I
ask is this this might be just a me
thing but no matter where I am or where
I'm performing or I always [__] my
things
I always perform with a little bit of
poop in my pants which is probably not
far hot and cold at the same time
foreign
[Laughter]
my my wee-wee like shrinks up a little
bit it wasn't that far yeah you get that
like you get a little yeah you Turtle
hey she sucks in on it I get performance
Adderall dick it just kind of comes on
top of my ball bag and just rests there
yeah it's your body scared yeah you know
even if you're not nervous like your
body's like oh we're about to go do this
thing that is inherently scary isn't
that weird because we're going out there
to make people laugh right but
instinctually and genetically that's
there to protect us from like a saber
Too Short yeah yeah yeah that exact same
response our body gets as if we're
entering the jungle with a [__] spear
but we're just going up there tinder's
weird my dad hurt me hey God knew what
he was doing protect the goods I know
what I'm saying and what's weird is like
that um that doesn't give you a lot of
confidence no if it should grow is what
it should do yeah go and go out with a
hammer yeah dude that saber too saw that
[__] yeah just chopped off yeah little
like almost post that you ever see that
Bieber dick pic he like came out
oh dude it's like clearly post sex
because it's perfect it's still a little
red but it's got like the Gonzo knows
dangle and it just looks like he just
had a good time but it's not fully it's
still got room to grow of course yeah
it's good piece well I got a tour around
out there I got a tour concept to
picture Mike Mike Cannon presents
fluffed up
now we're talking yeah that's my solo
pod
just you wailing on yourself the whole
time welcome back to
back to today's guest is you can only go
so far though each app is a cool 60
Minutes on One Celebrity guy's deck yeah
I don't hate him that's actually pretty
good
um that's great you want to do anything
special because it isn't you're a New
York boy you're doing The Gramercy
theater it meant a lot to us and we're
not even you know uh New Yorkers but it
is one of those things are you doing
anything special here's the thing man
it's like not I don't know if you guys
do a lot of like Pomp and Circumstance
or like fireworks or you have like like
yeah we got a pyro guys brought an
entire like native Indian group out
there and they're doing dances
[Laughter]
is his uncle but uh so I that like puts
pressure on me or it feels like there's
pressure to like make it a spectacle to
make it a thing the craziest thing that
I'm doing is like my wife is designing a
floral backdrop okay there you go yeah
so that'll look that'll look cool
I wanted to have a marching band come up
right down the line that'd be cool come
up on stage did you guys do anything
like that like did you have a dancer
like a Subway dreamer with a tiger yeah
on a spackle tiger that we killed after
each show it was expensive we lost all
that we lost all our profit but that
might be the move should I get a spackle
bucket Subway drummer to just [__]
open up the show yeah there you go okay
if you have any leads on one hit me up
yeah just go spackle box a couple of
Showtime kids that's right I pay an
exposure get up get them up there get a
homeless guy to come up and take a [__]
on the stage
this is a New York show yeah there you
go really New York it up lady selling
churros couple of Transit cops
ladies the churros during the show all
right interrupting I'll be quiet they're
not that bad down there no the subway
churros are pretty good were you banged
up huh were you banged up when when you
ordered a Subway churro no I'd get them
during the day yeah he's on his way to
work dude
no for breakfast he's on his way to his
office cinnamon sugar all over me dude
I'm like deep in Brooklyn the only
chance I'll buy those things if when I
was like shit-faced and just ready
whatever they give you like 50. they
give you because you ordered 50.
away
all right let's quit screwing around
Gang This is a family episode yeah we
got Mikey Cannon here we're gonna be uh
doing your questions from the patreon
there right now I don't like when you do
that
yeah some guy on the street or something
sometimes I just fall into him I can
feel the eyes on me like I'm in the hole
now when you panic a little bit but he's
dead what do you want from me have you
hosted like a game show or TV show or
are you just like do you look up to Dick
Clark because you do have very like host
by the book sure Vibe you know what I
mean yeah I did the dating game that
ain't [__] host a game show what are
you talking about fight game show money
I hosted Cosmo sexy versus skanky really
I think I remember that I think I think
I just moved to New York or something
like this guy's famous it's one of the
most embarrassing embarrassing games I
would see it stand on New York I was
afraid to make eye contact he does a
show with glamo
cabal holy [__] he has no security
[Laughter]
wait who was it for Cosmo Cosmopolitan
magazine where was it where did it air
nowhere we just recorded it for
ourselves and uh it's good I'll give you
a copy of it that's how people watch it
I gotta get them a flash drive if
they're interested they had a couple of
tapes at home
is your VHS paper but it was me Lindsay
Rodriguez who was like one of the final
hosts of TRL on MTV she's like this hot
Australian woman uh and I was like the
injected male opinion I was supposed to
be the dudes dude and you could tell
because every time I go to speak they
just like cut to somebody else it was
just wildly inappropriate the entire
time red meat titties
women are stupid and they're like all
right
I was at that point in my life too like
a 25 year old kid just like angry at
women because she's a [__]
it's Madeleine Albright take it easy
will you
even more so well they'd be like body
language is just as important as verbal
language and I'm like well then why
can't I read consent from a foot tap
like oh Jesus all right get out
um well yeah my cousins had a bunch of
cosmopolitans when I was young tug your
little root to it ever I would go
through every single page and read some
of the Articles well because the
Articles were something to learn how to
give the best [__]
did those do it for you because I had
those articles
whatever yeah this is pre-internet you
know yeah that would you're at least
learning something like oh [__] yeah
like erotica that's the benefit of us
growing up right as there was almost a
gradual incline to porn sure whereas now
you are just [__] in double
penetration video I mean we had to go
like pictures on the internet because
your internet couldn't handle the movies
VHS yeah whatever yeah DVDs jerking off
to a magazine yeah
was such a weird thing
there was a lot it was East Bay
he had good deals
they're going you're going nuts over the
cleats have you ever tried jerking off
to a Kelley Blue Book yikes laughs
did you guys hide or hide any of your
stuff I had a Playboy
my buddy Danny seliger this is how you
could tell like he had like he was nine
and his dad was like 400. he had like an
old dad all dads are tough every Cannon
story has a first and last name of a
real guy oh yeah this guy and one one of
the best last name was Celica Celica one
of the best athletes ever could like but
he could pitch Lefty and righty but was
also like smoking cigarettes at seven
yeah like just you know what kind of guy
he would have his dad had Playboys just
on the coffee table yeah when we were 10
11 years old was he married no okay no
no that was just his oh that would be
and that would be next level of trash
right next to the leather love seat sure
we I had a couple I had a couple of
friends whose dad they're married
there'd be a stack of magazines next to
the turtle it and there'd be a couple's
shifted in there okay yes
discreetly discreetly but everybody kind
of it was very it was very Cosmopolitan
house they were very Progressive the
moms whatever yeah they were you know
yeah it was Playboy so you could kind of
get away tasteful yeah it's artists you
kind of get away with that I wanted to
read the articles about Michael Jordan
or something like that so my mom found
my Playboys because I put it in like my
memory tub like I had that Tupperware
thing of like all my report cards from
when I was a kid that'll break them up
dude exactly all your baby pictures are
ripped out going
like her sweet little boy and then
peeling off the thing and it's just like
Jenny McCarthy peeling her lips open
yeah hell yeah it was and uh yeah it was
but the worst thing I had I had like and
I blamed my friend Rob who like I wasn't
allowed to hang out with for 18 months
because I just completely shifted blame
to him for giving this to me that's what
you got to do I had a like a huge
plastic Ziploc bag with like cut out
pictures of naked women from different
Publications okay and cut them out dude
and I used to hide it under my [__] so I
got it I didn't even cut the pictures I
received the bag from a kid who was done
with them yeah and then I just eat was
on in his house yeah the fuzz was
cracked five stars GTA they're gonna
start they're gonna start sweeping the
cells as he put it the spark was gone
hey I'm just not feeling it with these
girls anymore you know what I mean all
we do is argue
shut up Trina
uh so you have her so yeah I used to
bury them under my shed in the backyard
because I had gone about really being
horny yeah you're burying I'm not
talking about like shovels and [__]
right you just sliding I mean I'm
talking like like almost rabbit digging
a hole like kind of like moving soil
putting them under there covering it
back up
just sipping a cup of coffee looking out
the window man that boy really loves
digging
she's gonna be an architect okay say
well you will but you know dude it is
true though like for a long time I had
real anxiety uh worried anytime it
rained because I thought the rain would
like displace the pictures like kind of
wash them onto my backyard oh no dude
just living in panic you loved her you
know
I said he loved her the girl
we um wait it was the same girl or
multiple girls okay I thought all right
okay that's what I originally thought
it's just all Sarah Michelle Geller yeah
well hey I wouldn't hate that uh we
stashed them underneath a abandoned
tractor trailer that was in the woods
nice not a good look no I don't know how
it got there that's devil worshiper yeah
yeah we put it under where the top where
the extra Tire would have went did you
find them there or did like did you find
them in the woods because Woods were a
big place to find Woods work good place
like No Country for Old Men
[Laughter]
you find the buzzer and throw it it's
too late
some fifth grader shows up at your house
what's the most you ever lost on a coin
toss Mike right
oh
shout out to no country has a goddamn
[__] star-studded event rules
uh I've mentioned my uh kid I grew up
with his Dad owned a bunch of
independent rental store like video
rental stores they went out of business
he just kept all the all the porn like
he sold everything else and kept all the
point it was the kid did her the dad did
yeah he was not great
um like floor-to-ceiling boxes in his
basement like the money boxes and blow
dude it was like everywhere it's two
it's two and a half yeah yeah it was
those in one copy of Mrs Doubtfire was
weird which I called I got dibs
um yeah gazanga's three was the first
one we clipped from there no [__] I
watched uh all right flamingo ride on
that was my first ever porn I watched it
with my buddy Timmy his older brother
Billy and like five neighborhood Affairs
like five of Billy's friends you know
you had one tape one TV and then I I
went into the bathroom because you know
I felt uncomfortable I'm like hard and
dizzy and I walk into the bathroom piss
came out and like they all were looking
at me and I was like mostly come That's
how little I knew about sex I was like
that's crazy right guys I just came in
there and I was like he'd come out oh
you very didn't
we stole our magazines from a a place
called paperback Trader in our hometown
which had I was like a bunch of old
books and then I guess to [__] bring
a little cash in yeah keep the foot
traffic
gotta get them in the door with the news
nobody's coming in for Paradise Lost you
know what I mean
coming in for the action Larry Flynn
over here sex cells
a couple of Jane Austen novels and
[__] Hustler
a couple of cherries did you got were
you early on AIM too because I talked
about this with somebody recently but I
used to go AOL in semester I used to go
into the chat rooms like At first I was
like in basketball interest and talking
I was like wrestling and stuff like that
and then I would go into like divorce or
sex or whatever and I'd be talking to
who I assumed were divorced women but
probably some sort of old guy yeah yeah
and like talking about how to spice up
their marriage and like whatever how old
are you I'm like 11
[Laughter]
my grandparents one computer in their
living room looking over my back as my
grandpa's watching the Giants and I'm
like you know talking about you're 11
years old trying to tell tell some lady
had a spice different yes does your
husband like roller coasters
Dolores you got to get the magic bags
you need to go to Action Park lady yeah
the show was sponsored by better help oh
yeah gang if you got some things going
on and you want to feel empowered do
yourself a favor get over to betterhelp
and get on that online therapy yes talk
to somebody uh-huh I got to I've been
telling you for two three years now you
think I'm your therapist I ain't I'm
screwball sign up it better help promo
code a better visit betterhelp.com
garbage get that big noggin in your
straightened that I gotta do something
I'll tell you that gang yeah
um better help is therapy uh is a
therapy option that is convenient
flexible and affordable and entirely
online you fill out a brief
questionnaire get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge
it's easy peasy lemon squeezy I'm a big
big proponent of uh talk therapy it's
fantastic it has changed my life
multiple times throughout the times I've
done it sure uh different phases of my
life when you need it and stuff like
that it's great I highly recommend it
with better help it's easy to PG side
getting making the call or going to
visit the guy it's the hardest part this
you at least get in the therapy pool and
then you can stick and move figure out
what works for you you know I used to
hate going I know though you do it right
in the house do it on a turtle it if you
want to Turtle it uh if you want to live
a more power life therapy can get you
there visit betterhealth.com garbage
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help h-e-l-p.com garbage
do it gang don't be Looney Tunes out
there yeah Kibby it's time for display
this Play Let's Go don't be a bozo what
are you doing banging holes in the wall
look at the top quality of this product
right here you want cool posters to put
on a wall with magnets get over the
display you can make your own in 20
seconds and they also got nice licensing
deals with South Park they got aliens
they got Fight Club whatever you need
over there yeah got a little Seinfeld
here if you can think it display can put
it on a gosh darn metal posters the only
poster going up in my house nowadays put
your butthole up there I guess you could
I mean rated R thanks I'd have to come
into this
[Laughter]
uh it's fantastic on everything as you
know we're big Seinfeld boss so this is
the one we got Hachi Machi check it out
gang you're cool this is a poster for
the uh the older gentleman or gal you
know what I mean this ain't Spencer's
gives black light posters this is Art
this is wall art that's what I'm calling
it [__] metal uh click the link in
our description to see some of our
favorite displays and save up to 34
Hachi Machi you get 20 27 off when you
buy one or two and 34 off when you buy
three or more discounts will
automatically be applied to your cart
when you click the link or use code
Garbage When you visit displate.com
that's displate.com code garbage or
click the link in our show notes gang
come on now back to that gosh darn show
yeah thinking about it now like they had
to have known it was a kid they had it
just in terms of like Cadence and the
words of course all that [__] but I'm
thinking I'm aging myself up to 45 and
like crushing the game you're saying
[__] like boobs are red
show them your cool boobs maybe that'll
do it maybe if you show me your cool
boobs I'll tell him about your cool
boobs
is he still putting his wee-wee in your
cooter
the unique Cooter was a big one yeah
the Cooter shout out to it I feel like
we're in a sleepover right now I'm
chubbing up I'll tell you that
uh Thomas is Cannon to get some pizzas
in here Lee
a couple of Bagel Bites throw on
Gremlins let's go oh that was another
thing I used to I've jerked off at
sleepovers when my friends have gone to
sleep late night Howard Stern and you
try to like Magic Eye the blur we like
to see a ship in the middle of a
painting but it's a labia and then this
big nose comes in the shot and ruins the
whole vibe yeah but you know the voice
something about The Voice still helped
it move it along if he was off if he was
off cam but he was just like oh yeah
Howard can have a real sexy voice when
he's talking to somebody trying to get
something out of him yep ooh man you
really get into it uh I was always the
kid in a sleepover I just got lost in a
memory
oh man wow I really really went down to
yell he shook me out of it Kevin you're
sweating
it's been days it's Tuesday I have a big
beard I gotta get to the grammar scene
they're big beards
oh dude I was gone
holy [__]
where'd you go tell us all that about it
I will you're talking Howard uh my uh
friend of mine uh uh went on Howard girl
we grew up with the hot girl we grew up
with Ed on Howard we were no kidding uh
we graduated it was going into freshman
year of college I guess
yeah we were out of high school I was
going into freshman year college and she
went on to become like they they took
three girls and she she became a
playmate holy [__] yeah and but my buddy
was over at my other buddy's house and
like he called me like a hundred times
at like 8 A.M and I'm like what dude
he's like
he's like [__] it's topless on Howard
right now
[__] took the chopper up today's book
Kevin on the phone right now
I remember that drive to that it was
about 20 minutes away from my house yeah
I was hauling ass
Shadows on Howard Stern topless right
now I went blowing red lights oh yeah
you get pulled over where you going so
fast boy you know Shannon
follow me young man
this fat little bathroom gonna jerk off
in his friend's mom's bathroom
two motorcycle cops
you got a helicopter following behind
you
hey man you got present business Ah
that's a good time right there that's
where I went if you're curious hell yeah
I like it that's like getting drafted to
the majors dude that is a huge moment to
be on Howard and then land Playboy yeah
here this is her that's small town like
Olympics oh yeah this is what you went
by
yeah oh yeah you guys don't name names
that's probably smart
uh I forgot it was a big show
[Applause]
you my friend Phil Henderson
uh Mr siracola
oh man
she went to high school yeah holy [__]
just a yeah she's come to our shows
before talk about matter I'm sure talk
about not having a shot huh look at you
she dating dudes that were like in
college and [__] there was nobody that
hot at my school really that's that's an
anomaly they were hot foreign
that almost looks like like yeah it's
like plastic toy Hot sure where you're
just like this Almost Doesn't Even
register as a person sure yeah you're
like alien Okay so I don't have to
respect you yeah it could treat you like
you're not even real and have no
feelings makes it easier to chop her up
and put her in the cooler it might keep
barrier under the [__]
cut her up into pieces it'll be a real
girl they'll never find her even I don't
care how much it rains you're gonna get
along with the other girls real well
[Laughter]
your mom's looking at the back again
you're no good huh
I forgot
you guys don't name names
good good idea I was always the kid at
the sleepover that fell asleep last and
woke up first and it was torture no
anxiety dude yeah
I hated it everybody would be asleep I
couldn't sleep just laying there all
jacked up on Sour Patch Kids and then I
would [__] fall asleep when they wake
up at like 6 a.m and I'd be the one
upstairs having caught like sitting
there with coffee with the dad yeah dude
just sitting there he's like you you
want something Tony doing in school
I had a friend's best the exact same
woke up early and would smoke cigarettes
with my dad out on the driveway he was
12. I wasn't ripping heaters I had a
bowl of kicks or something why yeah In
fairness he's one of like six Irish kids
I think they lived on top of each other
he had a stressful existence so my
father gave him the green light yeah Hey
listen you know I don't condone this but
but I get it you got a rough paper
around town
what are you taking your coffee huh
a little bit of Bailey's a gentleman
all right oh you brought your own
whiskey
thanks for coming Sean you said to you
Dad like if you ever need a little extra
work hit me up I can help you ever
looking for sideworm
notice the crown molding is not finished
downstairs who you using by the way
did you have like anxiety as a kid like
did you have diagnosed anxiety or you
just thought you were like a nervous guy
ah undiagnosed everything still has it
all no sure
ask him he's working on it with an
attitude
where can I make it worse that's what
macro dosing every day is yeah yeah take
a cool two grams of mushrooms every day
and I'm just kind of rainbowing through
life yeah it's really grit in my cheese
oh man
um the macro dosing when you come out of
it though you feel a little bit better
oh 100 it's a real tough ride though
yeah yeah I have a visual drug use yeah
it'll do that I have a period during
mushrooms where it's like if I take a
full dose there's a solid it's anywhere
from like 30 minutes to an hour where I
call it nope where you're just not
allowed to talk to me you can't come
near me I gotta process and deal with
what I'm going not a great time
weathering and then once I then then the
Elation of mushroom mushrooms shots in
and then it's social then that's a
different part of the trip yeah but
there's like an internal period where I
need to sword fight my demons for a
solid hour yeah it's like digging
downward to get out yeah yeah very
strange yeah um but yeah I'm diagnosed
all the way through yeah they didn't
know anything about that I had acid
reflux when I was a little kid and no
and they didn't realize how healthy kid
he was I just thought everybody's
[__] throat felt like it was on I got
bunions after having bacon in the
morning like literally
killing me up until in my in my 20s it
was the first time I started taking
anything for it and I probably had it
since I was 11. holy [__] yeah rough go
yeah not bad I had a buddy who was like
we called him baby he was so small in
high school he wrestled at 97 pounds
blonde hair blue-eyed just a classic
Target and now he is
260 pounds deckered the [__] out and
he's as tan as can be jet black hair
he's a Dominican man
he's a monster too monster yeah but he
used to get uh the reason I brought him
up he used to get a hardcore migraines
at sleepovers and my my mom would feel
so bad for him because he's a sweet
little Swiss Miss boy and Mrs Cannon I
don't feel good can you call me I mean
so she'd have to stay up with him at
[__] 3am migraines is a little kid
yeah my sciatic is acting up a little
bit but that's that same [__] it's like
undiagnosed anxiety they didn't know
anything about that [__] back then I
learned about it nothing I remember my
dad going
I was like panicking over something he's
like oh you're all weary wart I'm like
that's also because you're a unhinged
I mean you fly off the handle on any
chance you get dude that might have me
on edge a little bit pal when I was in
my 30s I described depression to like my
sister and I was like you ever like feel
anything like that or does that like
because nobody in our family has ever
gone through this before and she's like
what do you mean our grandpa put his
service revolver in his mouth in front
of the family and I was like all right
cool like that that might have made me
feel less alone when I was a kid yeah I
didn't know what anxiety was and I was
describing I don't remember that
Thanksgiving
I'm like yeah do you ever have to like
you're somewhere and then you just have
to leave and they're like what I'm like
yeah that's every day for me I just
gotta [__] just gotta get the [__]
out of whatever I'm doing
yeah that's anxiety I'm like oh okay I
have a thing now which which uh uh
anytime we anytime like even when we
went to Disney to film any type of
travel that's vacation-esque massive
anxiety about it no because you know as
much as I love I love the fam and all
that stuff every single vacation we ever
[__] went on no matter what there was
always a war yeah between them me and my
brother would start [__] and they would
just be like this anxiety of were you
flying as a family never yeah no I never
flew with my family either my mom took
diet pills for a little while yeah
she was flying then
she's rocking a couple Sexes from back
she was kidding Patty I love issues on
those fat burners that killed those
football players what's that what was
asper no not aspartame but it was
ephedrine yes ephedrine yeah when those
kids they were like doing two a days in
the NFL and like two linebackers just
[__] keeled over yeah we rocked those
back in the day yeah I also rocked
something called Mini Thins which they
sold at 7-Eleven but it would get you
where you needed to go sure many things
they did they were they were some kind
of like bronchial dilator or something
like that I don't know what it was
sounds like poppers
it like amped you up it was some type of
amphetamine yeah yeah [__] man that's a
clear butyrol which is like what they
found in Canelo Alvarez's meat and it
was like a ped but it's a horse asthma
medication or something like that I take
albuterol yeah what was he a dog put in
his meat so it makes you grow lean
muscle and like shreds you the [__] up
it's what I said I took like over the
countertop thyroids and I stacked it
with that but it also Tremors you out so
you like are just I'm walking through
life like this constantly I'll just be
fat dude yeah now I think that way yeah
but back then I was like what's life
without ABS sure hey you're telling me
if you ever want to find out come to my
house
all right let's quit screwing around
let's get into some cues sure
guys so as you know when you sign up for
the old patreon over there I gave him
the pitch okay that was rude guys as you
know when you sign up oh no no no when
you sign up for patreon answer your
garbage question on here uh Toby's ball
massage that's a new one new ten dollar
homie that's Toby's burner
totally not Toby but Toby is great
uh is it garbage to come out of the
bathroom and say she's all yours to the
next person
I watched a female nurse saying it
ruined my day
tap in your style you got a newspaper
under your arms she's all yours
I mean that you at least know you're
about to walk into an active it's not
great yeah yeah but it's kind of it it
depends what you want do you want to be
surprised like walking into your
bathroom up here I walked in and there's
an old man that that works on this floor
that potentially has the most rotten
[__] yeah yeah there's a couple of
tough cookies up here I mean he is dying
he's a dying man but his colon it might
have been fully after being honest no it
wasn't me I know exactly you're talking
about yeah he has like halitosis of the
sphincter
[Laughter]
I stopped walking him before with a
couple Checkers bags
but yeah I mean at least you know there
was no neutral green bar I'll tell you
that if he came out and was like she's
all yours I may have been okay with it
sure but I'll walk again and seeing him
get like spooked and almost you know
died
oh you smell the [__] ghosts of his
past oh man
um that bad that's not a good bathroom
no it's tough bad no it's brutal I get a
little
um when a lady comes out of the bathroom
and you go in there and you and and you
know
there was some some work being done in
there yeah really I don't know what it
is besides worse not for you nah it's
not for me I mean okay that's not I
don't know why I don't know if that's a
hot time I mean yeah
it's also you're like it's work I've
I've walked in the bathrooms I've walked
into this bathroom last week that I am
it's like I am a disgusting it was I was
comical it was like somebody said all
stink bombs in there it was like
comically smelled like poop let me put
it this way it just throws me off I'm
not expecting it it's like a punch in
the face that hurts
look at me you're like I'm not you know
goddamn trucker you gotta redo the
drywall and stuff like that yeah if you
walk through the Lincoln Tunnel you
wouldn't come out smelling good either
sure sure
I remember I have one time it's always a
surprise you catch it like oh God damn
that came out of that yeah when someone
hit you with the uh someone took a [__]
in there like I had that happen where it
was like a single bathroom I was like
waiting yeah
a single person on face value is like
you know what that's a truthful that is
probably just doing push-ups in there
hey big guy
posted something for the gram yeah
you're in there for 48 minutes I was
peeing I did some laundry through a
loading I have an inflamed prostate it's
trickling out I bring a towel with me to
put it over my shoulder I just grabbed a
shower that's when you know it's bad
when you [__] have to dress like a
black comic to [__] because I have a
towel over your shoulder you Craig
Robinson mop your brow after each push
there's nothing worse than that a home
run of a question yeah
um all right this one's from undercover
Grimace first time long time merch for
things you don't own a Harley Davidson
t-shirt or perhaps a Ferrari hat
uh I remember my dad had Porsche driving
gloves one time that I think he wanted
like a golf outing and I was like seven
and I'm like that you shouldn't be
having these this is you drive a Jeep
dude
that's a tough look I don't know did he
use them to drive no they were just like
in like he got them I assume like some
raffle I think something right and they
were like poor striving goes with like a
hat like a Porsche they also sometimes
they sell those at like flea market like
my family used to go to the Stormville
Flea Market most of my youth was spent
going antiquing with my parents she's
like [__] brutal yeah and they would
absolutely like have no empathy for us
never let us like check out toys or like
get us something really incentivize us
to be human beings sure we're on
blacktop in the middle of Storm King New
York in [__] August those were the
worst it was just in parking lots were
so bad cars are like trying to like or I
mean dogs are trying to like get under
tables to seek shelter like it's that
type of hot sure and my dad's like what
do you think of this old [__] who
gives a [__] I'm just like dude I need
water
kids think this 18th century waffle
maker or look good in the kitchen
but they had they they would often have
like Ferrari gear sure like that Porsche
glove jackets yeah [__] like that that
was hot there I never trusted adults
that wore leather gloves I don't know
why OJ yeah not just that's why I'm
talking about the thin ones like not
like thinner than isotoners I don't know
why I just never trusted it like dry
like real driving gloves yeah I'm not
going with that guy yeah beat it I guess
you're kind of right I'm happy
something's happening in my body right
now that you're mentioning like those
real like when somebody pulls a glove
tight like that that had the the button
yeah yeah
get out of here my dad drove it back to
back like he was making money for a
short period of time and then you know
in classic fashion just lost it all yeah
we did the same thing uh he dropped he
bought a BMW 325i and that like six
speed you know Emmanuel it may have been
only five I have no idea but it went up
to a hundred when I was a kid and then
he had a Audi A4 Quattro and those were
his two like race cars those were his
babies and he would [__] just pull
those take it out for a Sunday yeah
Sunday drive drive Mach 3 with his child
in the back seat
I gotta lead on an old birdhouse yeah
did they ever have any like big scores
antiquing no no there was never any like
we bought something to make money so it
was only to decorate our home it was
like it was pointing out now like Pawn
Stars wasn't around none of that stuff
was really
I guess even in The Ether like nobody it
was only like resell it at your home at
your home during a garage sale when your
family gets destroyed yeah
nobody goes to see how much this is
worth family going at a business sale oh
dude I had to get rid of my ping pong
table I had to sell it to a friend when
my family's family broke up Jesus yeah
we had a divorce sale right on the
[__] driveway and I had to like
haggle with my buddy's mother about this
thing that I had to get rid of no matter
what and she knew it wait your mom
you're getting the cleaners I respect
that
beat up a little kid on price when his
life's in shambles worst day of his
goddamn life well it's not like your
parents are getting back together
put this in your dreams word on the
street is your dad's already seeing
somebody
makes you bring it over and deliver it
yeah what are you gonna put this in your
grandmother's house where your mom lives
or the apartment your dad yeah it's not
going to be able to turn the corner in
the basement what do you do this won't
fit in the room you're going to be
sharing with your uncle
wow that's [__] brutal yeah man
that's a tough one I would have took a
hatchet to it just to spike yeah I would
have burn it
took that money you [__] [__] it up
um there you go [__]
kicked a leg out from under it um all
right let's see here this one's from
garbage 10 home skill and ever to
question it is it garbage to dress like
you are classy but you commute to work
wearing rollerblades I guess you see
that in New York like a guy on a bike
with a helmet in a suit yeah or a
scooter a scooter is huge what the [__]
I hate doing that and they'll have like
a backpack on if you get a briefcase or
if you have a backpack just [__] put
your suit in it yeah like wear workouts
yeah we're normal clothes yeah because I
dude I used to uh I used to be a waiter
at this restaurant called pasta Amore in
Piermont New York okay and this is when
I was actually semi technically homeless
both my parents broke up I lived on my
buddy's couch his family's couch for
like five months and so I had to get
this shitty job while I was also trying
to do comedy for the first time and like
trying to also move into the city to
like start my adult life and I had to
ride my my Harrow my BMX bike yeah and
you say
yeah either one I don't know but I was
[__] I was rudely corrected in a BMX
shop so I've never made the mistake
again oh it's horror apparently ah [__]
that guy who cares but I would that the
bike is like 20 inches off the ground
I'm 6-1 and I'm in a shirt and a tie
with black shoes I know I've seen that
guy
just as well be pushing a shopping cart
s at its view of just
doing endos hit the bumps and like kind
of turning the wheel
ciao you guys riding on pegs and stuff
uh
uh yeah that's tough yeah
you see it because I live up by the gwb
you see it dude's trying to not
pay the toll yes so they'll come in they
right they scoot over they rollerblade
over a skateboard all in suits yeah it's
like that's not the you know that's not
the lawyer I want on the case no I could
never get away with it I'd be sweating
my balls oh yeah well if you own your
own bird scooter and you're using it to
just go from Fort Lee to the A train and
then ride that's what they do I know and
I'm over like dude they ride out in like
gangs it does save money so I'm and
probably time a good idea but it's like
it does make you look like the city
don't hit them up for a little bit of
scratch it's not like a scooter charger
no you just crossed the bridge yeah yeah
easy peasy I don't like that I used to
not have a net on that no they pull one
up like I mean
up until like maybe before they they
started their construction on it and put
it up and I think it just they little
net on what on the bridge yeah now it
looks like a driving range yeah oh it
used to be just no it was just a railing
so nobody can jump yeah yeah yeah no
that was the spot man they all said
there'd be cars just pulled over dude
there's a guy that sits up there oh
really and I didn't know lost my big
puck table
I didn't know and like I walked to uh I
was all [__] up and I was like I'll
watch the sunrise from the bridge it was
like you know like the summer was just
just got started getting kind of light
I'm like I'll walk across the bridge
it's all [__] up shirts off like I'm
all I just look like I'm oh I had the
worst night of my life yeah and the
guy's like are you good man I'm like I'm
just really soaking it in man like
giving like real vague one last time
yeah real big lines about life man
sunsets you'll never see one like this
again you're gonna get while the
getting's good you know what I mean pal
dude when I was super fun like when I
was at my most destructive kind of
trying to end my own life through drugs
and alcohol my buddy Tim and I
in Piermont would go to the Hudson River
and we'd climb the fence and at the foot
of the Hudson River he'd pack a fat and
I'd do Coke off at DVD cases and smoke
cigs and we'd just be like
uh we gotta end this soon buddy
this has gotta end soon yikes yeah
Welcome to Hell fellas
no movies first time I've seen Toby just
like it's a Gramercy theater on uh
February 25th February 25th ladies and
gentlemen this guy's a real ball of
sunshine let me tell you
childhood trauma and more
you want to do something special get
that broad that [__] low baldy on the
ping-pong table up there I see her in
the gym wait where still in my gym so I
I we moved back to Rockland during the
pandemic right and uh I I go to a gym
which is like far enough out where I
don't run into too many people from the
way you gotta do it and but I run into
her she goes there all the time she's
like a jacked older lady really yeah huh
she good looking kind of I mean yeah
definitely she could get it I wonder if
she still has the table they did they
have a new table I've been there we're
still friends with her son gotcha so and
he has a baby so we'll sometimes like go
over there and she's like you want to
play ping pong and I'm like are you
trying to reopen it Jesus don't broaden
I'm kidding she's probably a nice lady
and I respect the fact that you beat me
up thank you
dude
write that down
foreign
doctor's appointment
[Laughter]
actually not Karen no but also you give
him a fair gauge of it this is where I'm
at sure I'm not trying to church that's
like brushing your teeth a thousand
times before you go to the dentist hey
I'm Raw dogging this this is where I'm
at this is what this is my day today
this is a more realistic interpretation
of my body than if I ate salads for four
days heading there sure I've gotten
hemmed up with that where I didn't not
eat before blood work and like I ate
like I normally ate yeah and they like
called me like that afternoon yeah you
gotta get in here what the [__]
cholesterol is 88 000.
yeah you ever hear sagalo's story about
that where he like went to get his first
covid test and his blood drawn and he
has a horrible thing with needles and he
like tells the lady and she more or less
pushes them aside calls him a [__] and
is like you'll be fine and then he woke
up seizure I had a buddy man as soon as
you roll the needle out horrible pass
the [__] right out and she's like what
happened he's like I literally warned
you I told you I told you yeah I think
you're just being a [__] that's crazy I
have no problem with needles no it
doesn't even really hurt really no not
at all they usually have to go into my
whale skin
you just go
for a minute it walks over and lays in
the corner do you have tattoos no none
you don't thinking about getting one
though no kidding yeah what are you
gonna get uh I was gonna get my dad's
initials right here I'm thinking nice
yeah yeah that's not bad because it's
not Kevin's face right drinking before
tattoos oh you bleed out I don't care a
kid's older brother would do it a kid's
older brother would do it because you're
one of the sailors used to do well
you're not supposed to drink because it
thins your blood right yeah yeah this
kid came down holding the 30p it just
got like a chess piece or something this
kid came walking down the basement with
his shirt up over his neck just bloody
just gone looking like Denzel at the end
of training
you're just like what the [__] I
remember my buddy Timmy and I went to
Modern Age in Nanuet New York and he had
drank the night before and we got like
you know matching tattoos or something
queefy that's cute the guy literally
goes touches his skin and it just
started pouring blood down yeah he's
like what the [__] he's like you must
have hit a seam
it'll save
yeah I don't uh I'm not a tat man no I
got a couple all mostly regrettable yeah
I just saw the one on your finger for
the first time oh this one yeah this is
a uh this is like in lieu of a wedding
ring because I just don't I don't I
don't wear a wedding ring either yeah
this one let the ladies know I'm still
out there right that's right you'll make
a mistake if the offer is good enough
and this one was for Mike uh D Stefano
and then I have the Grim Reaper doing
stand-up comedy on the inside of my arm
wait when did you get that like one
minute into steps right after I signed
up for my first government didn't even
do it yet you signed up then went to get
the tattoo two drinks I Gotta Buy I'm in
this forever yeah let's go waiting for
my name to be called out of a bucket
then I have Saint Michael the Archangel
and Gaelic on my uh left arms yeah then
I have uh a Gaelic knot cross on the
upper back where it's like more or less
just a [__] stamp put up top it's a
full Bullseye if somebody wants to shoot
a rope on it Guy Fieri on your calf
[Laughter]
and here I have the lyrics to Bob with
the Bob
thank you
you truly are a dirtbag Rockland County
special place dude you hit that because
we're the same age right yeah 36 yep oh
I'm 37 so yeah so
um that was a very SP Junior High in
high school and early 20s was a very
specific time
to really be a dirt bag of like the
tattoos got very popular rap music the
whole [__] well the words you drink
the tattoos it's like now like line
tattoos and whatever and like at least
Artistry is inside sure yeah barbed wire
and Chinese symbols and like my buddy
Rob crosses everybody I know has a cross
or some sort of word on them Rivals were
big when you guys were kids yeah I was
saying energy drinks were coming out
dude my buddy who's dead now had a full
[__] try like he's Ukrainian and the
other full tribal thing all over his arm
and it was like appalling everybody
that's walking around like Moana
yeah I don't it was tough dude everybody
because rap music was so popular and
like being tough yeah was such a cool I
wanted to be Jason Williams yeah there
you go white chocolate I wanted
everybody wanted to beat like that kind
of dirt bag was like you sold drugs you
did drugs you listen to rap you knew
somebody with a gun like everybody your
clothes were brutal tough dude yeah
jenkos and all that I mean jankos was
early but yeah when I think do you have
any nightly pipes those are the off
Brands right those were like the
your mom loved you sure okay yeah it
wasn't a completely dysfunctional house
yeah yeah you guys would be the same age
as AJ soprano the character right
probably yeah like Slipknot jackets and
all that kind of stuff he was younger
[__] hated those kids I wasn't a
slipknot kid though I had that album
that album was all right
[Laughter]
yeah fashion wise it's all like cool now
which is weird it's weird to see but it
is funny that like it's like ironic it
became ironically cool to wear like a
big baggy clothes and Oakleys sure and
[__] yeah it's it's very very Oakleys
but dude everybody I know has
like their son's face on their back oh
my God
uh just like sayings yeah only God can
judge me yeah he you know all that [__]
I haven't gotta be a killer to have my
friend has blessed like LeBron has
chosen across his [__] full back yeah
that's crazy that's tough I have one
buddy who's he had he had respect was
the first hat or loyalty yeah oh loyalty
loyal loyalty was big in the early days
we grew up and dude he was [__]
everybody's girlfriend and he's like he
had loyalty on it we're like dude the
irony of the like that's what you chose
we grew up in a very like loyalty tough
guy it was like you know yeah Ma like
good all that [__] and don't disrespect
don't disrespect loyalty family you guys
were kids what it seemed like that's
when kids were really getting hurt in
fights yeah we were like Fast and the
Furious you were hitting each other with
like pipes and [__] like that oh yeah
there was no just [__] mono Amano
duke it out it was like [__] Deadwood
you guys are [__] going and the nose
rings
that we never did that my friend my
belly button pierced for a short period
of time did you really know oh my god
dude I my heart
it was Panama Beach yeah braids in his
hair I went to the Poconos
in a water park
I was at Safari Sands what do you want
from me come back speaking a Jamaican
accent for a little while
one braid
for the weekend
[Laughter]
loyalty was huge early 2000s that's so
fun it's that's such a specific kind of
dirt bag yeah a white T-shirt oh a pair
of Air Forces a fitted hat and something
and like really holding a grudge
several miles in a grudge I'm in oh dude
your generation was primed for the pills
to take over yeah it was like the
perfect storm because we never told
horrible we were we weren't taught about
feelings but we were slightly emo oh
yeah so we yeah we just like thought we
romanticized being [__] up or at least
I did I really thought like that's why I
hung on to drinking for even like two
years longer than I should have some
still are that's right uh but I like
hung on to that image of like oh man
this is like what it is the loser comic
like I get to like wake up feeling like
[__] like that's how it's supposed to be
if I can see you being right at home
playing basketball solo angry oh yeah
dude you ever see Above the Rim creature
playing with no ball against the ghost
that he killed that was me at Veterans
Park in Orangeburg just crossing up
nobodies like me like get off me get off
me you can't guard me you can't guard me
you're not my real dad
there's an intramural team waiting to
play
there's a bunch of eight-year-olds these
kids eating oranges horrified you go out
and shoot around at their halftime that
was all oh non-stop oh really yeah
non-stop that was so that's like that's
not dude that was the corniest move when
like the older brother or whatever go
out and shoot around and they would kill
little kids halftime guys I would do it
at my now wife's then girl for high
school girlfriends games so listen this
is a crazy with a real fast
this is kind of a crazy story so I I
went to this game it was her AAU game
what I didn't know is that during the
game one of the coaches brought a water
bottle of vodka and she accidentally
grabbed it thinking it was hers she
didn't like spit it out whatever but the
dad was like sorry about that which
would be like front page news now but it
kind of just brushed off as oh she's
goofy now kids yeah so I went out and I
was shooting you know in between coins
you were older or younger same age same
age but we're like 15. all right so I'm
I'm out there and there was one break
where I was just unconscious I hit like
12 in a row just couldn't miss and I'm
playing with all these black kids and
then we come up on the bleachers and
after they did this whole thing where
they're like man we we're baptizing you
black we're you're good at basketball
you're [__] nice and they started
fake peeling off their skin and throwing
it at me and are like you're now black
dude
I've just held on to that forever yeah
like this is now my identity that's
right I thought you're gonna say they
asked you to be on the girls team hey do
you have a wig in the car by any chance
get you a dress
got a big game coming up when you were a
little kid yeah if you were at your
older brother's game or at like a high
school game that like your cousin played
on and it was halftime and you went out
there and shot around that was it that
was fine yeah trashy yeah let's put all
little dirt balls around on the court
but if you're doing it as an older kid
yeah no I was coming out and blocking
those children like I would do that
where they like a four-year-old would
come up and all smiles and then get out
of my house just thinking somebody from
Nike or Adidas is gonna be there Phil
Knight is sitting front row that's him
right there shoe dog did you have the
and one mixtape vhs's yeah every one of
them yeah every single one of them I
also I we I so I went I was good good at
basketball early and then I flamed out
obviously but I uh I went away to like
Coke down by a river that was later
that's later that's what everything was
away
it sounded like
not far off Jesus Christ what was I
saying I don't even remember who cares
you were dunking on some 12 year old
girl yeah who cares I flamed out uh
let's go oh we gotta wrap it up here
gang Mikey this has been this has been a
real who's you guys are the best well we
[__] my yearly checkup
you're still a certified pencil me in
for once a 12-month favor
hahaha
somewhere with me come on it gets worse
we find out more than God damn the ping
pong table's all right
um ladies and gentlemen
February 25th The Gramercy theater Mike
Cannon super funny get those tickies do
yourself a favor you know them you love
them go see him we love you Kippy what
do you got for him uh we're all over the
road we got dates get those tickets
those tickets are moving quick we want
to see and we're adding more dates we're
coming everywhere so just hold tight
it's gonna be a good time making you got
anything else you want to throw with
them uh here's the scenario podcast of
course sagalo and Feeney Fun Time start
with your episode you guys have been on
and uh yeah we got to get you back
Toblerone you're you're welcome as well
we gotta we gotta do this hell yeah good
time we love you buddy thank you we'll
see you next week peace